well i have to ask how do you feel about  being a popular meme  in the last few years because there's a  lot of good ones there's  you sipping tea yeah yeah yeah uh as  they say in the  social media circles it's not that easy  being meme  but uh you know uh you know something  about a frog sipping tea that that  speaks to everybody  this is like a little star wars kind of  thing i like this one yeah  that's a picture of uh that's me and my  evil doppelganger constantine the frog  from muppets most wanted  oh my god i love it i love it well um  it's been a challenging year so what do  the muppets want everyone to know  you know what kelly i think we've all  discovered that  even even when we're not together in the  same place  we we can still check in with each other  and take care of each other and if we do  that every day then  we'll get through this and we'll be able  to we'll be a bit better for it you know  yeah i love the optimism  [Music]  you